je parte
déjà sur un karting à l'âge de 9 ans
adrien le floch se retrouvent dix ans
plus tard au volant d'une alpine a110
cup de 300 chevaux à peine sortie de son
deuxième test de la journée adrien a
déjà pris ses marques sur la voiture et
son lot de sensations
on a commencé un peu sur graseck et puis
là du coup ça a commencé un peu à
pleuvoir donc humide à la fin mais
franchement super j'apprends bien dans
toutes ces conditions là donc c'est
parfait passage obligé pour progresser
le manager d'adrien débrief la séance
d'essais avec la vidéo tu vois
progressivité c'est à dire qu' il n'est
pas à la relâcher
soit tu gardes un filet de gaz soit et
progressif il ya toujours un petit
stress à ce qu'est ce qu'on dit est ce
qu'on a bien fait et ce qu'on va se
faire un peu grand v se taper sur les
doigts etc mais généralement non ça se
passe très bien car pour l'écurie c'est
un test mais avec un gros enjeu
constituer l'équipe junior pour le
championnat alpine elf europa cup 2022
pour adrien qui débute on a vraiment sur
tous les points de freinage et filer
vers l'efficacité aux freins il ya plein
de petits points qui font qu'il va
gagner des dixièmes de seconde au début
donc c'est très important la vidéo faut
qu'il progresse qui roule et j'espère
avait la voir au sein de mon team cette
année au championnat pour qu'on puisse
travailler cette saison est de faire au
mieux et c'est reparti pour une nouvelle
séance d'essais sous l'oeil attentif des
parents d'adrien quelque peu étonné de
le voir s'épanouir dans cette passion ça
aurait créé un événement parce que c'est
quand même la première fois qu'il monte
dans une voiture aussi cylindrique celle
ci est alors bon à part moi et se
déroule très très bien mais bon il a ça
dans la peau quoi donc depuis qu'il est
tout petit non il s'est fait son dossier
puis après ils démarchent des grosses
entreprises pour essayer justement
d'avoir des sponsors quand même et c'est
lui qui se débrouillent de tout ça au
fil des essais adria prend confiance
plaisir aussi il veut gagner sa place
pour cette première compétition douze
courses dont 4 sur les circuit mythique
de monza barcelone ou encore magny cours
le but à terme c'est devenir pilote
professionnel en étant recruté par une
marque quelques porsche aston martin et
s'étaient eux-mêmes lamborghini fin
d'une première journée dans le grand
bain pour adrien très confiant et serein
pour la suite car rien n'est encore joué
on verra sur compatissent de la faire
avec le team pour cette saison 2022 est
en tout cas je l'espère je me suis très
bien senti aujourd'hui donc j'espère
signer et que mon premier pas vers mon
grand rêve se réalisera un rêve qui
pourrait démarrer le 15 avril à nogaro
et aboutir en apothéose sur le circuit
paul ricard en octobre adrien mais en
tout cas toute son énergie pour que son
nom figure en bonne place dans la liste
des grands pilotes